the AfD
fortunately wins 1 path
gains 1 popularity in the population
11 years ago
I have fled from Germany emigrated
back to my father's country
I stand behind Germany
but not behind the
what the current policy has made of Germany
I hope
that the AfD will become so strong in the coming years
that Germany becomes livable for Germans again
and this is what I say
who is only 1/2 German
but I stand behind the AfD
behind its policy
and I hope that someday I will be back in 1 free
Germany can return
by being safe normally
and can live with visions of the future and not in the
what Germany is at the moment
we hope it gets better soon